et chatouille
ajouté c'était quoi chatouiller si
c'était des petits rené vous comme sa
droite à gauche sur le blu ray ne plus
quoi il faut bien les forces et ils ont
pu former les enfin
comme si jamais sur counter d'après je
vais vous dire que la gamine et gonesse
et ce répertoire sur le bout des doigts
et le messin et tué des centaines si le
monsieur parce que je sais pas
il faut pas mentir aux led faut pas
mentir la cour d'assises est
elle le dit pas mais elle avait sa
a non mais je me procurais un projet que
j'avais forcé la gamine a été lu au
mieux car
on ne peut pas forcer les gens là ne
veut pas dire non partant des padres
je veux dire deux choses
ces deux mêmes qui ont levé la culotte
la garmin alors
c'est moi
c'est moi le bar messieurs dames
andrea bescond n'a que 8 ans quand elle
est violée par un ami de ses parents son
calvaire va durer près de quatre ans il
a fallu attendre de longues années pour
qu'elle sorte de son silence et que son
agresseur soit condamné
dans son spectacle autobiographique les
chatouilles qu'elle joue à genève lors
de la journée internationale des droits
de l'enfant elle retrace l'enfance
brisée de la petite odette huit ans
chaque année en france cent cinquante
mille enfants seraient victimes de viol
ou de tentative de viol des crimes resté
dans l'oubli car la honte et la
culpabilité empêche souvent de parler le
faisait de ça j'ai jamais rien dit
forcément j'avais sa langue dans ma
bouche alors je pouvais pas dire grand
chose
après ils descendent et sa main et la
plongée et avec ses doigts et gratter
fort ils appellent ça les chatouilles
mais moi quand même ça le relais
j'ai vraiment l'air con avec cette tête
de lapin bordel
jboss
après moody's et garde cela je connaisse
son truc les williams vilalta bouche je
comprenais pas et comme les pousser ma
tête de mamba a d'abord sa mort ou alors
je m'exécutai
à ce moment là que c'est toujours un
râle bizarre j'ai regardé et est tout
beau tout conflit comme là bas on aurait
dit qu'il a explosé il était moche
à l'automne 2010 est une décision
judiciaire choque l'opinion une fillette
de 11 ans ayant eu un rapport sexuel
avec un homme de 22 ans voit son
agresseur acquitté par le tribunal
l'écart d'âge n'a pas suffi à le faire
condamner pour les victimes de viol ce
verdict est choquant
cette notion déshumanisation qui se met
en place qu'on a été un enfant violée en
fait non de manière tout à fait
personnelle moi je passais par là et et
plus je rencontre de victimes
plus je vois qu'on est un peu tous dans
le même cas et qu'il faut tout
reconstruire derrière tout réparer en
fait faut tout réparer pas guérir vous
savez pas malade c'est resterait
paresseux réparer doucement doucement
doucement mais c'est vrai que de d'être
reconnu en tant que victime par la
justice par la famille par son entourage
quand même quelque chose que salvateur
quoi pour réfléchir à une réforme le
sénat met en place un groupe de travail
au sein de la commission des lois
l'enjeu créer une réponse adaptée
et la méconnaissance et que ces tensions
ont chanté bombes et des conséquences
sur leur vie reçue par les sénateurs la
psychiatre muriel salmona explique les
conséquences à l'âge adulte des
violences sexuelles subis dans l'enfance
c'est possiblement 20 ans d'espérance de
vie en moins c'est le premier la proue
le premier facteur de risque de
mortalité précoce de décès précoce
premier facteur de risque de suicides de
dépressions répétition de conduites
addictives en fait tous les grands
problèmes de santé publique premier
facteur de risque d'obésité troubles
alimentaires de troubles
cardiovasculaires de maladies auto
immunes de l'immunité
diabète acheté à au cours de leurs
travaux les sénateurs vont étudier la
question du consentement et celle du
délai de prescription pour permettre aux
victimes de porter plainte après leur
majorité
geoffrion presse en france il n'y a pas
de seuil inscrit dans la loi qui
permette de dire qu'en dessous d'un
certain âge un acte sexuel entre un
majeur et un mineur est un viol emmanuel
macron souhaite instaurer un seuil à 15
ans la garde des sceaux a évoqué 13 ans
le parlement va devoir trancher nous
devons protéger les enfants et si ce
n'est pas écrit dans la loi c'est notre
rôle de législateur d'écrire un seuil ça
nous permettra nous qui sommes là aussi
pour reposer certains interdits dans la
société si on écrit ce seuil nous aurons
l'impression d'avoir fait notre travail
de législateur est de contribuer au
mieux vivre ensemble dans une société
actuellement selon le code pénal le seul
écart d'âge entre un mineur et un majeur
ne suffit pas pour condamner une
personne pour viol il faut prouver que
l'auteur a commis un acte sexuel avec
pénétration en usant de violence
contrainte menace ou surprise
[Musique]
si l'une de ces quatre conditions n'est
pas démontrée l'auteur n'est poursuivi
que pour délits d'atteintes sexuelles et
non pour crime comme l'expliquent
jean-claude marin le plus haut magistrat
de france lors de son audition la grande
différence entre relations
sexuelles c'est la problématique du
consentement dès lors il y a
matin sexuelle sans consentement et dans
l'agression
lorsque l'on à
la question sur un mineur on
estime qu'ils aient eu consentement mais
dans l'atteinte sexuelle
le mot consentement on est écrit nulle
part dans le code pénal celui que l'on
juge c'est l'auteur de l'infraction at
il exercer une violence une contrainte
une menace ou une surprise pour parvenir
à l'acte sexuel au tribunal de bobigny
le juge des enfants edouard durand
estime qu'il faut faire évoluer le droit
je pense que les affaires récentes
qui ont beaucoup ému la société sont
très importantes parce que les personnes
dans les familles les professionnels
dans leur travail la société dans son
ensemble
nous sommes parvenus à nous représenter
la scène sexuelle et donc à être choqué
par l'idée qu'un adulte d'une trentaine
d'années et une fillette d'une dizaine
d'années pouvait penser la même chose de
l'acte au moment où ils étaient commis
par l'adulte contre l'enfant
chez la plupart de nos voisins en europe
il existe un seuil d'âge en dessous
duquel un mineur ne peut consentir à un
acte sexuel avec un majeur ce seuil
minimum est fixé à 13 ans en grande
bretagne 14 ans en allemagne en autriche
en italie et au portugal
à 15 ans au danemark et à 16 ans en
suisse
ancien de la star academy est
aujourd'hui engagé en politique mathieu
johann nous reçoit au conseil
départemental de la manche pour lui
l'enfer a commencé à l'âge de 7 ans sur
son lieu de vacances où ils passaient
tous ses étés l'animateur du camping lui
faisait subir des viols à répétition
maintenant c'était un peu amouraché de
lui et finalement lui c'était seulement
amouraché de moi et donc il m'aimait
fougueusement me disait-il il abusait de
moi donc ça durait un mois un mois et
demi et puis les les rencontres se sont
un peu moins espacées puisque maman l'a
invité quelques fois la maison et qu'on
allait le voir en banlieue parisienne
moi j'étais très partagé entre le fait
de ne pas avoir de papa donc d'avoir
peut-être un papa de substitution et
n'ayant aucune en plus éducation
paternel je ne savais pas si c'était
bien ou pas ce qui se passait je sentais
comme un truc pas normal mais quand on
n'a pas de repères quand on a 7 ans 8
ans 9 ans 10 ans ben on se laisse faire
ces puits ont
consulté et on hante et le calvaire va
durer des années jusqu'au jour où il
reçoit l'appel du père d'un ami de
vacances qui a découvert que son fils
était lui aussi victime du même
prédateurs il me dit bonjour c'est
jean-jacques est ce que tu vas bien
tu es sûr tout va bien
et là c'est un peu le début de l'enfer
d'un autre en faire ses débuts en fer
judiciaire tu me dises yonnais par un
mec qui me posent des questions
complètement dingue quoi avec du recul
kim humilier davantage
il faut que tu me dis tout ce qui t'a
fait ce que est ce que tu as pris son
sexe dans ta main est-ce que tu l'as eu
c'est enfin des choses qui étaient
j'avais l'impression d'avoir
d'avoir affaire à des adultes totalement
administratif et je me sens une fois de
plus
non pas victimes mais coupable de ce qui
s'est passé parce que je suis un je suis
un petit garçon de 11 ans et demi qui
qui qui t'est pas préparé du tout à tout
ça
après un long processus de
reconstruction mathieu johann s'engage
avec la voix de l'enfant
cette association a créé une
cinquantaine d'unités d'accueil médico
judiciaire le but favoriser le recueil
de la parole des mineurs victimes de
violences donc tu en seras proximité y
est de la seule l'audition qui du coup
c'est pareil comment la brigade de
recherches de saint malo reçu à l'unité
de saint malo la présidente du groupe de
travail marie mercier va à la rencontre
des acteurs de terrain ici gendarmes et
psychologues travaillent main dans la
main pour auditionner les enfants on a
commencé à faire un groupe de travail
d'abord avec les gendarmes
depuis 2007 et donc un groupe de travail
qui s'est transformée en groupe de
formation continue en fait
pluridisciplinaire et qui vit depuis dix
ans ce groupe de formation qui dont se
réunit on a
facilement maintenant 30 35 40 ans de
quatre heures qui viennent à chaque coup
en lançant on en fait on en fait deux
parents général et puis on si on forme
les enquêteurs qui arrive on fait des
erreurs quand on est quand on est
enquêteur quand le ton le bon on est un
petit peu peur quand on a un enfant sa
salle où est on veut pas se tromper on
va pas de traumatiser on voit pas qu'il
soit plus traumatisées qu'avant qu'il
arrive devant nous donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse un peu à la façon dont
oppose aux questions et c'est vrai que
par exemple moi j'avais tendance je
posais une question où l'enfant en me
répondait pas tout de suite je reposerai
une deuxième il répondait pas aux films
troisième et c'est là que j'ai appris
j'ai fait mon travail mon travail sur
moi même j'ai appris à laisser les
silences lui laisser le temps parce que
lille n'a pas le même la même
construction à saint malo tout est fait
pour mettre les enfants en confiance
l'unité d'accueil est situé dans
l'hôpital et non au sein de la
gendarmerie pour éviter aux victimes de
vivre leur interrogatoire comme une
expérience traumatisante à l'image de ce
que mathieu johann a vécu des outils
adaptés à chaque tranche d'âge ont été
mis en place et l'audition est filmé
cela constituera un élément de preuve
pour les magistrats
aux enfants vous stick la caméra les
tirs on glande plafond les micros pour
l'enregistrement audio le fait que l'ue
peut expliquer avec ses mots à lui ce
qui s'est passé et que si c'est
compliqué il va aussi une service le
dessin servir trois écrivains se
redéfinit ce qui s'est passé à ce moment
là il glissa fabienne suter qui en
connaissant ce qu'ils poursuivent
audition on a mis en place depuis un an
maintenant des pictogrammes qui n'arrive
aux enfants qui ont peu de l'engagement
de pouvoirs et mis en confiance avec les
petites scènes de la vie quotidienne
enquêteurs présentent aussi un enfant de
parler et pour donc les enfants parce
qu'ils peuvent eux aussi être gêné de
montrer les parties donc voilà on as
version version en version filles
peuvent pointer là où on leur a fait du
mal là où ils ont été touchés
de l'autre côté de la vitre sans tain la
psychologue va orienter l'enquêteur dans
l'audition du mineur équipé d'une
oreillette
ils sont en lien permanent
l'objectif est de déterminer en cas de
viol s'il ya eu violence contrainte
menace ou surprise c'est toute la
question du consentement qui se joue ici
la psychologue est là pour le bien-être
de l'enfant à tout moment elle peut
interrompre l'interrogatoire
si le mineur est trop en souffrance on a
la possibilité de
zoom et
603 de la table
les
conti transpire on voit aussi qui
transpire sur cette table
quand l'enquêteur va lui demander
raconter avec ces homos admis ce qui
s'est passé il va être obligé de se
rappeler de se remettre en condition de
l'agression du contexte de l'agression
donc c'est redire en fait c'est vivre à
minima ce qui s'est passé donc on va
être très vigilants à son bien-être
psychique et puis on va guider
l'enquêteur pour que ça se passe le
mieux possible pour lui
enregistré l'audition du mineur est
transmise aux magistrats chargés de la
faire
selon le haut conseil à l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes 60% des
victimes de viol sont des mineurs mais
parfois il est difficile d'établir s'il
s'agit d'un viol ou d'une relation
consentie et la notion du consentement
est laissée à l'appréciation des
magistrats
fréquemment dans les audiences
que je dois président et j'entends de la
part des agresseurs toujours la même
phrase qui est
il ou elle disait rien il ou elle était
consentante à ce qu'il disait rien
le progrès c'est de dire que la
contrainte est constituée dès lors que
l'enfant a 13 ans et moins
s'agissant d'un acte commis par un
adulte sans qu'il soit possible
d'apporter la preuve contre sinon on
reviendrait à l'état du droit actuel
alors comment faire en sorte que le code
pénal protège mieux les mineurs au sénat
les auditions se succèdent ministre de
l'enfance sous le précédent quinquennat
est désormais sénatrice laurence
rossignol a rédigé une proposition de
loi sur le non consentement tout l'enjeu
est de définir un seuil d'âge
j'entends bien qu'il y à des seuils
d'âge de maturité qui sont différents et
qu'entre 13 ans et 15 ans il se passe
des choses dans la maturité sexuelle et
affective d'un d'une jeune fille ou d'un
jeune garçon d'ailleurs qui amène
certains à proposer que entre 13 et 15
ans on continue de conserver deux
critères de l'écart d'âge pour
déterminer s'il ya eu ou non contrainte
et que le viol ne soit présumée avec une
présomption irréfragable que pour les
moins de 13 ans
13 ou 15 ans tout le débat a lieu autour
de ce seuil ce qui explique que certains
magistrats soient fermement opposé à la
création d'une présomption de non
consentement irréfragable irréfragable
c'est un terme qui signifie que l'on ne
peut pas apporter la preuve contraire ce
qui va à l'encontre des droits de la
défense
concrètement ça veut dire que si nous
avons un une
victime et qui est âgé de 14 ans et 11
mois donc moins de 15 ans si on a
retient l'âge de 15 ans pour discuter la
pression retient de 15 ans comme
qu'hommage
4 d'une victime qui a 14 ans et 11 mois
qui a une relation amoureuse avec un
garçon qui lui a 18 ans et 1 mois et
bien nécessairement si une relation
sexuelle avec pénétration
le garçon comparaîtra devant la cour
d'assises et ne pourra pas échapper à la
condamnation
à la devant la cour d'assises une
présomption irréfragable
c'est une conque une présomption qu'on a
pas le droit
d'essayer de détruire
cette une valeur absolue qui dit en deçà
d'un certain âge on a pas de
consentement c'est pas la peine
d'essayer de prouver le contraire
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas de défense
pénale possible c'est de mon point de
vue contraire aux principes fondamentaux
des étapes droit et vraisemblablement de
notre constitution ça serait le congo
conseil constitutionnel le utile face
aux risques anticonstitutionnelle la
réflexion se poursuit la question sera
tranchée par le parlement lors de
l'examen du projet de loi sur les
violences sexuelles au printemps 2010 8
mais au delà du consentement le sénat
étudie le principe du délai de
prescription des crimes sexuels commis
sur mineurs
2 litres les gars
90% des viols sur mineurs sont commis
par un proche de la victime et le milieu
sportif n'est pas épargnée en saroubi
man sébastien way était violée par le
mari de sa cousine pendant son
adolescence il s'investit maintenant
dans la prévention et la formation des
professionnels de l'enfance ce soir il
est à marcoussis au centre national du
rugby face à de futurs entraîneurs
tous les vendredis il fallait que je
parte avec lui que je rentre avec lui ce
que savait pas mes parents c'est que
cinq minutes avant de me ramener me
violer
et a pris buvait le café répare donc
donc voilà comment fonctionne le
prédateur pour lui c'était une relation
sexuelle consentie
on parle de consentement actuellement
pour lui c'était ça alors que c'était
bienvenu violé des crimes ils étaient
trois amis trois victimes du même
prédateurs
sébastien bay a mis 18 ans à briser le
mur du silence il porte plainte à l'âge
de 30 ans sans pouvoir imaginer les
conséquences que cela allait avoir j'ai
convoqué toute ma famille et tous mes
sens quelque 30 et après tous mes
cousins cousines en été j'avais une très
grande famille
j'avais perdu les deux tiers dès que
j'en ai parlé
c'est pas des réactions qu'on n'est pas
prêt avant ces réactions puisque on
était une famille et se disant lié et
malheureusement quand les quand on est
victime dans une famille on est le
caillou dans la chaussure donc non c'est
pas c'est pas c'est là où j'ai connu ma
première dépression en fait quand j'ai
parlé le cas de sébastien braye n'est
pas isolé la famille préfère parfois
rester dans le déni après le procès il a
créé son association pour protéger
d'autres victimes potentielles on va
leur apprendre à identifier leurs
parties intimes
et du moment que tu sais te laver seul
tablier seul qui a le droit de toucher
ses parties intimes donc c'est 3 et le
médecin même papa et maman ils ont plus
le droit de toucher ses parties intimes
parce que ton corps t'appartient est
acquis si tu as un secret qui te rend
malheureux à qui tu dois le dire donc
identifier la personne de confiance
quand je les ai vus partir 91 c'était le
début de ma résidence je suis passé d'un
nom de domaine est un monde apaisé et
comme je dis souvent ce que j'ai gagné
en ce que j'ai perdu en sensations je l'
ai gagnée à l'émotion donc mon le
français pour moi il a été aux
constructeurs et et ça a été vraiment le
début de ma résidence
un procès salvateur pour sébastien bay
qui a réussi à faire condamner son
agresseur à dix ans de prison mais comme
beaucoup de victimes millet koyama n'a
pas eu cette chance elle a été violée
dans le milieu familial à l'âge de 5 ans
par un cousin éloigné suite un choc
émotionnel les souvenirs des viols sont
remontées à sa mémoire 32 ans plus tard
des faits qu'elle avait complètement
occulté c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'amnésie traumatique en 2011 elle porte
plainte contre son agresseur mais les
faits étant prescrits l' affaire est
classée sans suite millet koyama
n'obtiendra jamais réparation devant la
justice si un dessin qui estampille déjà
ça c'est important 31 janvier
1978 donc quelques mois après les viols
que j'ai subi et on voit un homme
avec la moustache
mon père ne portait pas de moustache ont
agressé en avait une voix un enfant sans
bush qui est traversé par un serpent
lorsque ma plainte a été classée sans
suite ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
c'est qu'à l'époque comme donc les
souvenirs viennent de ressurgir mai donc
on a le sentiment qu'on est victime
seconde fois de ces viols en fait donc
c'est comme si ces crimes enfin c'est
comme si ces crimes on a besoin d'une
réponse enfin moi j'avais besoin d'une
réponse judiciaire à ces crimes et le
terme de prescriptions c'était presque
insupportable en fait c'est un l'idée je
peux la comprendre intellectuellement le
droit à l'oubli mais c'était exactement
l'inversé de ce que je vivais dans mes
émotions physiquement psychologiquement
intellectuellement faim depuis la loi de
2004 qui a allongé le délai de
prescription une victime a jusqu'à 38
ans pour porter plainte soit vingt ans
après sa majorité mais bientôt le délai
de prescription pour les crimes sexuels
sur mineurs devraient être allongées à
30 ans un engagement du président de la
république après une proposition faite
sous le précédent quinquennat
j'y suis favorable parce que je vous dis
que si on considère les phénomènes
d'amnésie traumatique qui parfois sont
évoqués ou pour toute autre raison après
tout je peux entendre
que ce délai qui est donc allongée de 10
ans par rapport à la situation actuelle
permettent de reconstituer un faisceau
d'indicés ou tour peut-être de
témoignages autour d'autres éléments qui
est après tout pourrait aboutir à
le souhaitent les victimes mais ce que
souhaitent les victimes c'est la
possibilité de porter plainte contre
leur agresseur quel que soit le temps
qui s'est écoulé après les faits faute
de réparation devant les tribunaux
millet koyama s'est lancé dans un combat
pour faire modifier la loi reçu au sénat
en tant que victime d'amnésie
traumatique elle raconte son histoire
ravir avec des commerciaux navire votre
demande merci des goûts très heureux
vous auditionné la gauche anti mois de
mai après je vous en prie merci
et millet koyama est décidé à faire
changer la loi en s'appuyant sur la
dernière réforme de février 2017 sur les
délais de prescription
notre combat aujourd'hui c'est se battre
pour introduire l'amnésie traumatique
dans la loi et notre notre proposition
en fait c'est de l'utiliser un des uns
des articles delà de la nouvelle réforme
de la prescription pénale sur la notion
d' obstacle insurmontable
c'est à dire faire en sorte que le
législateur considère que l'amnésie
traumatique est un obstacle
insurmontable et donc suspendre des
prescriptions et d'en permettre à des
victimes qui le souhaitent de pouvoir
déposer plainte lorsqu'elles sortent de
la musique romantique certains sénateurs
ne sont pas insensibles à cette idée à
leurs yeux l'amnésie traumatique
pourrait être reconnu dans la loi comme
un obstacle insurmontable permettant de
lever le délai de prescription et
société évolue
les protections évolué il appartient au
législateur qui doit ressentir la
société qui doit sentir ce qui se passe
lorsqu'il considère qu' il y à des
protections majeur à apporter majeur au
sens
exceptionnel
eh bien on doit pouvoir modifier aussi
la loi c'est notre rôle il n'y a pas des
choses qui sont figés dans le marbre à
tout jamais et puis là encore je redis
on on touche à des actes criminels
qui touchent évidemment des personnes
mais dans l'intimité qui est la plus
grande qui est la plus la plus aboutie
et qui marquent à vie les esprits des
cerveaux et des vies c'est 10 en 2013
parmi écueil âme à la cour de cassation
refuse néanmoins de reconnaître
l'amnésie traumatique ce phénomène n'est
pas prouvée scientifiquement
selon le procureur général jean claude
marin
il faudrait pour aller dans le sens d'un
décalage de la prescription prenant en
compte le troll l'amnésie traumatique
qu'il y ait premièrement un effort plus
exactement un progrès scientifiques qui
permettent d'objectiver cette amnésie
traumatique et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement que cette amnésie
traumatique cuisse
jallet dit à être au cas par cas
démontré scientifiquement
s'agissant de chacune et 8,6 l'amnésie
traumatique ne peut pas être reconnu
dans la loi certains sénateurs
réfléchissent à l'imprescriptibilité
pour les crimes sexuels sur mineurs
comme c'est le cas en suisse ou en
grande bretagne en france seuls les
crimes contre l'humanité sont
imprescriptibles
mais au sein de la plus haute
juridiction de france les magistrats
avant cela question d'épreuves
difficiles à réunir des dizaines
d'années après les faits une
imprescriptibilité des crimes sexuels
sur mineurs qui aurait des conséquences
bien plus vaste on pourrait imaginer une
escrime
presque la timidité mais c'est
imprescriptibilité ne pourrait pas être
décidées pour les crimes seul commis
contre les mineurs il faudrait revisité
l'intégralité de notre organisation du
temps utile pour des poursuites pénales
aujourd'hui nous n'avons comme au crime
imprescriptible que les crimes contre
l'humanité
il pourrait être j'ai à dire choquant
de déclarer les crimes sexuels commis
contre les mineurs
imprescriptible et de laisser à 20 ans
l'assassinât suivies de tortures contre
un majeur mais au sénat ébranlés dans
leurs convictions les juristes de la
commission des lois estime que le droit
doit s'adapter et évoluer j'ai voulu
parce que jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
beaucoup raisonnée simplement comme un
juriste à la fois comme un avocat comme
un membre de la commission des lois mais
que cela ne suffit pas
parce que c'est évidemment
pas seulement ça et il faut accorder
aujourd'hui la ce sujet là à travers
toutes ces tous ces prismes et
singulièrement en inversant le débat et
en s'occupant d'abord de la victime dans
sa champions veut protéger mieux
protéger les enfants en modifiant la loi
et le code pénal c'est tout l'enjeu pour
le législateur face aux affaires
récentes qui ont choqué l'opinion il
faut apporter une réponse à la
souffrance des victimes mais évitez
aussi une loi uniquement façonné par
l'émotion aujourd'hui seulement un pour
cent des plaintes pour viol conduisent à
une condamnation
le japon a de mauvaises relations avec
la plupart de ses voisins il n'a pas
signé de paix avec la russie avec la
chine et la corée ya un contentieux
mémorielle et un contentieux territorial
et les etats unis considèrent le japon
comme une puissance secondaire de toute
évidence le japon n'arrive pas soldé la
question de la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale sa responsabilité dans les
crimes qui ont été commis à cette époque
de la violence qui a été imposé dans le
cadre des politiques coloniales l'état
devrait normalement essayer de rétablir
une cohésion sociale mais il n'y
parvient pas
et comme il n'y parvient pas les gens au
pouvoir font actuellement du
nationalisme de pacotille qui leur sert
de soupape de sécurité jardin national
et zone
japon la tentation nationaliste samedi à
23h30 sur public sénat
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la chine est prête à se
lancer à son tour à la conquête de
l'europe en se posant comme sauveur de
la crise financière pourquoi la chine
investit tel autant en europe on en
débat avec la réalisatrice magali sert
le député olivier marc l'ex la
journaliste camille yihua chen et le
chercheur françois di milieu droit de
suite présenté par jean-pierre gratien
ce soir à minuit et demie
mcdf vous présente solidairement votre
[Musique]
être solidaire c'est permettre autant
que possible aux personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie de continuer à vivre
chez elles ce qui nécessite souvent des
travaux d'aménagement dans le logement
pour ne pas tomber dans l'escalier ou
glisser dans sa salle de bain et se
fracturer hanche ou genou vivre mieux à
domicile pour les personnes âgées est
une préoccupation particulière pour les
organismes non lucratif que sont la
mutualité française et les institutions
de prévoyance
[Musique]
car les plus de 80 ans représentent
aujourd'hui 11 % de la population et ce
chiffre va doubler d'ici à 2060 la
location de perte d'autonomie concernera
de son côté deux fois plus de
bénéficiaires en 2060 selon l'insee et
l'ined
le montant de l'allocation versée à
domicile est plus faible que celui versé
à ceux qui vivent en maison de retraite
moins de 1000 euros pour un célibataire
et moins de 1300 euros pour un couple
[Musique]
les organismes de la mutualité française
et les institutions de prévoyance réunis
au sein du ces types le centre technique
des institutions de prévoyance met en
évidence l'importance des actions de
prévention la mise en place d'activités
physiques ludiques intellectuelle pour
pouvoir vivre dans de bonnes conditions
à domicile le plus longtemps possible et
oui le médicament la pilule miracle
n'existe pas il faut vivre une vie
active
il n'y a pas de retraite pour le
mouvement
[Musique]
m -cd vous a présenté sous les gants
contre
les visiteurs du soir c'est quoi c'est
une rencontre entre une personnalité du
monde politique à une personnalité du
monde de la culture ce travers pouvoir
rencontrer d'intellectuels d'artistes
par exemple sur la question écologique
nous sommes préoccupe beaucoup il écoute
il dialogue avec au coeur de leurs
échanges n'ont pas la politique mais de
là les visiteurs du soir présentée par
nathalie cuman vendredi à 19h30
[Musique]